ahora
espero la cápsula freedom con destino a
la estación espacial internacional
la compañía de iron mask space ex en
asocio con la nasa puso en órbita a
otros cuatro astronautas cuando el
escenario para volver a la luna
a finales de este año vamos a lanzar
después de medio siglo para volver a la
luna y allí nos vamos a preparar y nos
vamos a poner a punto vamos a aprender
vender
y vamos a desarrollar nuevas cosas
nuevas técnicas nuevos sistemas
nueva tecnología para que podamos enviar
humanos ammar wickens en
yumen tumores esta es la primera
tripulación paritaria en un lanzamiento
al espacio está compuesta por la
astronauta jessica watkings la única
mujer afro que ha realizado un vuelo
espacial de larga duración así mismo la
única mujer astronauta de la agencia
espacial europea la italiana samantha
cristoforetti los hombres son el médico
convertido en caminante espacial kjell
lindgren y el astronauta novato bob
james quien conduce la nave
en tierra los espectadores apostados en
el parque space view en titusville justo
enfrente de la plataforma de lanzamiento
describieron su experiencia
quiero decir es increíble lo que están
haciendo por nosotros por la humanidad
arriesgando sus vidas para ella sabes
para traernos más conocimiento sobre
este universo en el que vivimos
la misión designada cruz 4 es la cuarta
tripulación completa de la estación
espacial internacional que la nasa lanza
a bordo de un vehículo de spacex el
entorno de microgravedad de la estación
ofrece a los científicos un laboratorio
único para realizar experimentos desde
la mecánica de fluidos y la combustión
hasta el crecimiento y el envejecimiento
de las células
el vehículo llegará a la estación este
miércoles en la noche